[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATHAN MARTZ: Hello, everyone.
Thanks so much for
sticking around
for the very last session
of I/O and the last session
in our Daydream series of
talks here at I/O 2016.
It's really fun to be here
to talk about Daydream
and to talk about it in detail.
Today we're going to talk
about building high performance
Daydream apps.
So as I'm sure you
all know, Daydream
is Google's new VR platform
for building immersive,
interactive long form VR
applications and experiences.
And when we talk about
creating immersive, creating
a sense of presence,
really what we're doing
is creating an illusion for
the mind, albeit an extremely
compelling illusion.
And today we're going to
get to the API's for how
we create that illusion.
But before we get there, we need
to understand why this matters
from a physiological level.
So there's two very interrelated
and important systems
to understand when you
think about presence in VR.
The first is your inner
ear, your vestibular system.
This is the part
of your body that
understands balance,
that is what
responds to when you tilt your
head, when you move your body.
The system is a
constant sense of where
your head is oriented in space.
The other system is your
ocular system, your eyes,
which of course are
how you see the world.
And normally, unless
you've eaten something
you shouldn't have,
those two systems
are perfectly in sync
with one another.
As you move your head, your
eyes adjust and your inner ear
picks up the change right away.
The challenge is that
in VR, there's actually
a lot of things that happen
between your movement, which
is instantaneously sensed
by your vestibular system,
and what your eyes see.
You have things like
when you move your head,
there are sensors
in the phone that
have to pick up that movement.
They send that to the CPU, which
is computation and simulation.
It renders.
It sends that to the GPU,
which does rendering.
And then the display
has to output it.
And then finally, it
gets to your eyes.
And the longer the gap
is between the movement
that you created-- what
your inner ear sensed--
and what you see on
screen, we call that motion
to photon latency-- the amount
of time from motion to photon.
And that's responsible for
how present we feel in VR.
A lot of lag, we
feel very absent.
In fact, you can even
feel simulator sickness.
And so really our
goal-- and what Daydream
allows-- is for you to get
below 20 milliseconds of motion
to photon latency.
And the focus of today's
talk is how you do that
and how you do it in
a sustained fashion.
There's another thing that
I think is really important,
which is at a higher level.
We're all building experiences.
We talk about mobile VR.
These are devices
that run on batteries.
They're seven watt devices.
But we're also in a
world full of computers
that plug into power plants,
the 600 watt devices.
And of course, we want to create
immersive, compelling, fun,
and engaging experiences
for mobile VR
that feel just as
good as the ones you
can get on high-end desktops.
So to do that, Daydream
provides a platform for you.
There's a hardware
component to the platform,
the phone itself, all the
Daydream certified components
in it.
And then there's the OS,
Android N, and it's VR mode,
a support for low latency
rendering and head tracking
and all of that good stuff.
So to tell you how to take
advantage of that hardware
and software
platform, we're going
to look at three
really key components.
We're going to look at
rendering-- how you actually
set the machine up to get it
to run in a low latency mode--
general performance and
optimization strategies,
and lastly, how
you can use audio
to save yourself a lot of time
and your phone a lot of energy.
So the first and really
key section is rendering.
This is where a lot of time
and compute goes in VR.
So let's say you start
with a Daydream phone.
Great.
In a simple version of
rendering, you're like,
I have a phone.
And then I render
to the phone screen.
That's our ideal.
I have a thing,
and I render to it.
Done.
But the reality
is that rendering
doesn't work that way.
It's more complicated.
So traditionally, 3D
apps are double buffered.
You render to one
image or texture
while the phone is scanning
out another texture.
But because there
are two buffers,
that buffering adds latency.
It takes certain amount of
time to scan one while you're
rendering to the other.
And so already you may have
16 or 30 milliseconds just
from that one step.
And in fact on Android by
default, not in VR mode,
it may add another
frame or maybe even
two frames of additional
latency as Android tries
to smooth out the experience.
So this latency,
which isn't noticeable
at all on a regular app or
game, is very noticeable in VR.
And so our goal
is actually in VR
to get back to that original
idea of basically you
render a frame
and it's instantly
available on the screen.
Ideally, we want zero
motion to photon latency.
So in the section that
I'm about to go through,
I have a bunch of
code, all of which
is extracted from samples
part of our new NDK.
I'm focusing on C++ here because
I thinks that's what most folks
here are interested in.
There are Java examples as well.
The short link at the bottom
is for the source code
if you want to follow along and
look at the unexpanded source.
In this section,
I've kind of cropped
out the interesting
bits and left
out some of the boilerplate,
which is important
but not as material
for this conversation.
So one of the most
basic things is set up.
This is in your
MainActivity.java file.
You have your onCreate
for your activity.
And the first thing
you want to do
is create a GVR layout,
which is part of RSDK.
And the GVR layout includes all
of the scaffolding for core UX
and UI in Daydream.
And it also is what's
going to give us
access to an internal
pointer that we
use in the native code
in just a little bit.
You want to create a GL
surface view-- standard way
of rendering to GL in Android.
And then after
that, you're going
to want to actually set a
renderer up, a native renderer,
for your surface view.
And when you do that, there's
two really important functions.
The first is onSurfaceCreated.
And you're going to
want to use a JNI
method to get from that Java
function into your native code.
In this case, I've got a simple
sort of mock C++ function
called initialized GL.
And this is what's
going to be called
from that onSurfaceCreated.
The first thing
you want to do is--
using that this
API pointer, which
you can get out of
your GVR layout--
is a GVR API initialize GL.
That kind of tells us, OK.
Daydream SDK.
We're about to get started.
From there, the next
thing you want to do
is say, hey GVR API
GetRecommendedRenderTargetSize.
And what's interesting is--
what that's going to do
is it's going to look at the
phone that the user is using,
and it's going to look
at the optical properties
of the viewer that they're using
and compute an optimal texture
size such that you get
one-to-one pixel precision
at the center of the lens.
Then you're going to need
to create a new framebuffer,
or framebuffer chain really,
by calling our offscreen
framebuffer handle function,
calling create to it,
and then passing
in the render size.
Now, the render size is
actually mutable intentionally.
The recommended size is not
the only size you have to use.
You may decide to use higher
resolution or lower resolution
framebuffers.
But the important
thing to highlight here
is that we're creating
an off-screen texture.
We're not rendering directly
to the front buffer.
We're rendering to an
off-screen texture.
And this off-screen
texture is actually
larger than the physical
display of the phone.
And we'll talk about why
that is in a few more slides.
So going back to
our main activity
on Java-- now that
we've set everything up,
the next most important
function is onDrawFrame.
And this is the tick function.
This is the heartbeat that
is going to pump our renderer
and keep us drawing
at 60 or 30 hertz.
So here, now we're back to C++.
Again, we use a JNI method to
get into C++ for draw frame.
And at the top of
the function, you
want to take that
framebuffer handle
that you've got in your
initialize GL function
and call SetActive.
You're telling our
SDK, all right.
We're ready to go.
We're about to start
drawing using the resources
that we've allocated for you.
Once you do that, you
need to get the head pose.
And the cool thing is
that you use our API.
You say, just, hey, get where
the user's head position is.
And you're
automatically accessing
all of the low latency sensor
data, all of the sensor
fusion, head tracking.
All that's in there.
You don't have to worry about.
It's one line of code.
We do tons of work for you.
And now you know the
orientation of the user's head.
The next step is to draw
the left and right eyes.
I've omitted the
details of that code,
but basically you're
going to draw the left eye
to the left side of the
image, the right side eye
to the right side.
And now you have--
hey-- stereo rendering.
Pretty awesome.
Once you've done
that rendering, you
need to do a couple
more steps before it's
really ready for VR.
The first is just calling
SetDefaultFramebufferActive.
And that's, again, we're
saying, OK, we bound this thing.
We render to it.
Again, SDK, we're about to
push it out to the screen.
And then you call
DistortOffscreen
FramebufferToScreen.
And you say, OK.
I made an offscreen framebuffer.
I rendered to it.
Now distort it, which
means do lens correction.
If you're not familiar
with that idea,
it's basically-- when you view
a virtual world through lenses,
really you're looking
at a screen that's
just inches from your eyes.
But you feel like you're looking
out on an entire virtual space.
The virtual view distance
is different than
the physical view distance.
And it's lenses that
make that possible.
But those same lenses that
let you see the screen
and feel like you're looking
on a world warp the image.
And so we actually have to do
a counter distortion, which
is based on the optical
properties of the lens,
so that you don't see all
straight lines looking
curved through the lenses.
So this
DistortOffscreenFramebuffer
is going to take care
of that lens distortion
for us using the undistorted
perspective that we've
provided.
So we have our stereo screen.
That winds up getting distorted.
And if you actually
look at your screen,
you'll see it's kind
of vignetted and warped
as we've done this
barrel distortion on it.
And then we're going to want
to do one more thing here,
which is-- there's a
technique that we use called
async reprojection where if you
think about what's happened--
where you called GetHeadPose
and you did some rendering
and then we said, hey,
GPU, go do this thing,
some time has elapsed.
It may be only milliseconds
that have elapsed,
but probably their heads
have moved a little bit more
just in the time it took you
to render both of those eyes.
And so what we do as part of
our distortion and presentation
pass is we take your scene and
we shift it just a little more.
At the last possible second,
we get the very latest head
position and warp again.
And that way it further
reduces the sense of latency
that users feel as they're
looking around the world.
And then finally
with that shifted
and corrected reprojected view,
we push that to the scene.
And that's what you see
on your phone-- except
actually not quite.
We're not quite done yet.
So the other thing
that's really important
is that if we just
naively took that view
and rendered it
to the screen, you
would get tearing because the
screen is actually refreshing.
It's being rescanned over
and over and over again.
If you have a single block of
memory that's being scanned,
and you just sort
of write blindly
into that block
of memory, you're
going to see ripping
on the screen.
You'll overwrite maybe
part of the screen
as it's being updated.
And it's really unsettling,
especially in VR.
So in order to update
the scene right away
but do it without
tearing, we have
to enable a feature
called ScanlineRacing.
And what ScanlineRacing
does is we
know exactly where the
scanline is in the display,
and we make sure that we
update right behind it
so that it kind of
looks like this.
But basically, we
make sure that we're
updating slices of the
display just in time for them
to be scanned out.
And when you get all that
timing exactly right,
you have the
minimum latency that
allows you to draw it
directly to the front buffer.
And that's kind
of cool, I think.
Also, I really like
this animation.
It's fun.
It's like so many
programmer hours
to make that animated
GIF a reality.
[LAUGHING]
So there's a couple more
things that you need to do.
Basically, what we
just talked about,
that gives you the fundamentals
of low latency rendering
in Daydream.
But we're not quite done.
And if you just
did the previous,
some things wouldn't quite work.
Back to Java-- there's another
function that you need to call,
which is setVRModeEnabled.
This is basically saying, hey,
Android OS, turn on VR mode.
And when you do that, some
really important things happen.
The whole Android N VR
mode stack comes alive.
A lot of functions turn on
or allow you to turn them
on because you've said, OK.
We're in VR mode.
And it's even a cue for things
like, oh, notifications should
no longer be rendered in mono.
They need to be
rendered in stereo
because we're telling the
machine that the user's now
in VR.
Also, the Daydream controller
requires that VR mode flag.
So if you want input,
you have to be like, hey.
I'm in VR.
Otherwise we won't talk to
the controller and waste
battery on it.
So the last thing is you want
to enable sustained performance
mode.
And really one of the other
challenges of smartphone VR
is that we're not just trying
to do low latency rendering.
We're trying to do it in a
sustained fashion in a way that
works on a phone for
minutes, tens of minutes,
hours at a time.
And what sustained
performance mode does
is it actually
manages the hardware.
If you're not familiar
with the details of how
phone hardware is designed,
most phone interactions
are very bursty.
The phones in your pocket,
it's not doing much,
just waiting for a call.
Then you pull it out.
You unlock it.
You check your email.
You browse the web, and
then you put it away.
And so the phone wants to
kind of turn on and go burst
when you launch your web
browser and then back off again.
Well for VR, we're running
really hot, really hard.
This is sustained stereo
60 hertz rendering.
But if the phone was allowed
to run at its peak speed,
it would actually
generate more heat
than the phone can dissipate.
And so sustained performance
mode tells the OS, hey.
Manage your CPU and GPU
a little bit differently.
Run at a lower
peak speed in order
to maintain your throughput
for a longer period of time.
Last thing you need to do is--
in your AndroidManifest.xml,
there's two tags.
The first is the VR
mode tag, and the second
is the VR high performance tag.
VR mode is a permission.
You're saying, hey, I need
to be able to have access
to VR mode in my app.
And then the high performance,
it's basically like,
I am a Daydream app.
I can take advantage
of the Daydream API.
You can set this required
flag to either true or false.
If you set it to false, it
means that maybe I'm actually
also a traditional
app with a Daydream
mode in a self-contained
VR environment.
So I don't require Daydream
for my app to be installed,
but I'll benefit
from it if it is.
However, you're saying, no.
I'm building a
Daydream only app,
and I only want it to
be available to users
with Daydream ready phones.
You want to set that high
performance tag to true.
You're saying, I require this
to exist for my app to run.
So a lot of you probably
think oh, that's great.
All the C++, I'm glad
that I understand it,
but I don't do that.
I use game engines.
And that's why we're
doing native integrations
with both Unity and Unreal,
the two most popular game
engines for VR development.
And what these native
integrations actually
are using the same NDK
that you have access to
and actually incorporating
most of the same functions
I've just shared with you, but
into these large professional
code bases and
making sure that it's
bubbled up through the ecosystem
and settings and all of that.
So if you're a Unity developer,
we have a plugin available
right now, but it doesn't
take advantage of all
the Daydream optimizations.
That won't happen until the
native integration this summer.
For Unreal, that
native integration
is available right now in
the 4.12 developer preview.
So I'm going to talk more
broadly about performance--
things that you want to be
thinking about whether you're
writing your own engine or
using a game engine that's
commercially available.
So when we talk
about performance,
there's a tendency
to think mostly
about polygons and pixels.
You're like, oh, is my
character too high polygon?
But the thing you actually need
to think most about when you're
talking about performance
on smartphones is thermals,
is heat.
Like I said, your phone is
capable of producing more heat
than it can dissipate if it runs
at its absolute maximum speed.
And phone SOCs are
designed that if they ever
generate too much heat, they'll
actually throttle themselves
back.
They'll slow down.
In fact, they'll
slow down a lot.
They'll hit the brakes to cool
down enough that they can then
speed back up again.
And if you're in VR, you
don't want that to happen.
You don't want to be
running at one frame rate
and then slow way down
and then come back.
That's like sitting in
a car that's speeding up
and slowing down.
We want smooth,
steady frame rate.
And that's much more a function
of thermals then of raw pixel
count or polygon count.
The other thing to think
about is recognizing
that both the CPU
and the GPU generate
heat, as is all the
interconnects between them,
system memory,
all of that stuff.
And the CPU and the GPU
are on the same diode.
They're very close
to one another.
So if you're generating a
lot of heat from the CPU,
that will affect the thermal
budget available to the GPU.
Similarly, if you optimize
things on the GPU,
it'll make the
whole system cooler.
So remember that
you're thinking through
a self-contained package.
And it's a whole
ecosystem that you're
optimizing for and thinking
about the thermal profile of,
not this sort of abstract
and interdependent parts,
though you might
think about them
on a console or a desktop PC.
One of the most basic
optimizations on the CPU side
that should be thinking about
are batch counts or what
some people call draw calls.
Every 3D object
in your scene has
to be processed by the CPU,
handed off to the driver,
in order for the
GPU to render it.
And that of course, takes work.
It takes computing, sometimes
quite a bit of work,
to prep that geometry
and send it down.
In fact, when you profile
a lot of your apps,
one of those common bottlenecks
is that they're CPU-bound,
simply trying to feed the GPU.
This is the reason
APIs like Vulcan
exists, is to lower
that overhead.
If you're targeting
Daydream, especially
in sort of this year frame,
our somewhat conservative
recommendation is
that you target
100 batches, 100
draw calls, per eye,
or about 200 batches per scene.
You may find that for some
games, you can do more,
or for some apps
you can do less.
Engines, code bases,
all that stuff varies.
But to give you a
very basic bottleneck,
it's something to think about.
Another way to actually
reduce your batch count
and run more
efficiently generally
is to bake everything
that you can.
Anything that's
static that doesn't
need to be computed
dynamically, compute statically.
So one great example is you
want to combine local instances
of static geometry.
For example, there's three
rocks on the ground there.
And they're the same rock model,
just rotate with one another.
And normally, if you
just place each of them,
that's three draw calls,
one for each rock.
But it's often for VR
a good optimization
to combine them
into a single mesh.
Of course it's more polys,
but you're saving batch count.
And you're really not
rendering much more.
You still have to render all
three rocks from the GPU's
perspective, but the
fact that you submit them
once is a lot more efficient.
And engines like
Unreal and Unity
have built-in optimizations
called static batching in Unity
or actor merging in Unreal.
And those are great ways
to take content, author it
in a normal way, but then crank
down the number of batches.
Light mapping looks fantastic.
It takes some memory, but
memory is relatively cheaper
in terms of you have a lot of
memory on these modern devices.
So doing high-fidelity
lighting calculations offline
and baking them totally helps.
One other really
clever trick-- if you
have control of your camera, if
you're in a fixed environment--
is past a certain distance,
the stereo effect kind of
goes away.
And so if you can pre-render
your backgrounds-- render them
into an ODS, a 360 stereo
pano or mono pano--
you can just blit that right
to the screen like a sky box.
To the user, it will
look just as real,
and you'll save
yourself a ton of time.
One of the things you
really, really want
to be thoughtful about
is the bus, basically
the circuitry that transfers
data around the SOC.
This is one of these things that
you tend not to think about.
Like, oh, there's memory.
And it's accessed randomly.
And it's fast.
But actually, one of the
most energy consuming
operations on the SOC is
just reading and writing
for main memory.
And of course, when you're
talking about framebuffers
that are 1080p 1440p,
that's like a lot of pixels
to move around.
Textures that are 4K
by 4K-- all of that
is data that has to be shuttled
back and forth from main memory
to the GPU and back again.
So some ways that you can manage
the amount of traffic you're
putting on the bus--
the first one is you
can actually tweak the
offscreen render texture size.
Remember I said we need
that original function.
We said, hey, give me the
idealized offscreen target
size.
That's just a suggestion.
You may find that for your
particular application
you can run much
smaller or much larger.
So iterate with that.
See what is the right balance
of performance and fidelity.
This is one of the biggest
kind of constant optimizations
you can make to your app.
You always want to use
compressed textures.
A lot of mobile
developers are used
to not compressing
textures because maybe you
don't have that many of them,
you don't like the artifacts.
But in 3-D, you want
to compress things.
And Daydream ready phones have
all the latest ETC2, really,
really good texture compression.
So take advantage of it.
It will save you a
tremendous amount
of bus bandwidth and energy.
And then the last
thing you need to do
is avoid full screen passes.
A very common pattern on
desktop and on console
is you render your
scene, and then
you have another
pass for shadows
and another pass for bloom
and then depth of field
and then vignetting.
On a phone, each of
those full-screen passes
usually means reading
from the main framebuffer
and writing back to
the main framebuffer.
It's like millions of pixels
back and forth across the bus.
Instead, what you want to do is
be very judicious-- basically
don't do full screen passes but
build them into your shaders
to the extent you need
to do them at all.
So something like tone
mapping, where maybe you're
going from HDR down to LDR.
Try to do that actually at
the end of your pixel shader
so that you only have to read
and write to the framebuffer
once.
In general, though, you want
to prefer the vertex shader
to the pixel shader.
Modern GPU's are homogeneous.
Whether they're processing
verts or processing pixels,
they don't matter too much.
They will do whatever
you tell them to do.
But there's often 20x
fewer vertices onscreen
than there are pixels onscreen.
And so if you can do
something per vertex
rather than per pixel, that's
a 20x reduction in the amount
of compute the GPU has to do.
And so really, when you look
at your shaders, get involved,
understand what they're
doing, and anything
you can move to be per
vertex and interpolated--
even if it's not
quite as perfect--
is probably a giant win
in compute and in thermal.
And in general, you
can target-- again,
a little bit conservatively--
about 100,000 verts per eye
or 200,000 verts per frame.
Now I should mentioned
these budgets are assuming
you're rendering at 60.
If you're rendering at 30, which
I'll talk about in a second,
you've got a little
bit more headroom.
In fact, this is
the other thing--
because we have
async reprojection,
we will actually
update the displays
at 60 hertz-- even if you're
rendering much slower,
we will keep
updating the display
to the best of our ability using
async reprojection to correct
for the user's head movement.
So apps will look best when
you also render at 60 hertz,
but you can render
at lower rates.
You can render at 30 hertz.
And what you'll see is
you'll render a frame
and then we'll
output two frames.
And depending on the
app you're building,
that can look totally natural.
The most key thing, no matter
what frame rate you target,
is to pick a frame
rate and stick to it.
If you're going from 20 to 50 to
30 to 40, users can feel that.
And it will feel unsettling.
So a stable frame rate no matter
what you do is really key.
I'd recommend for
most developers,
especially early on,
try different things.
Evaluate.
Experiment.
Don't lock in early on,
at least not until you've
done those experiments.
If you are rendering
at 30 hertz,
it's really tempting
to then spend
33 milliseconds on rendering.
But actually, if you're
running at 30 hertz,
you want to do that to save
power, to save energy output.
So actually use less than
33 milliseconds of compute.
Let the phone cool down a bit.
So if use 20 milliseconds,
it's still more than the 16
you get from 60 hertz
rendering, but think
of that as a
power-saving strategy,
not just a way to spend
twice as much time rendering.
And lastly, profile,
profile, profile.
One of the awesome
things about Daydream
is that it's on
Android, and you get
the benefits of
the entire Android
ecosystem for profiling--
Android Studios,
GPU profiling into bugging,
Qualcomm's profilers,
Nvidia's profile-- sorry.
Qualcomm gets an additional
Daydream hardware.
And you also get so much
just out of the box.
You get Unity and
Unreal's profilers.
If you write your own engines,
all of that sort of stuff
is really, really
available and powerful.
The last thing I want to
mention is make it a habit.
Be thoughtful about this
in your team's workflow.
It's natural for teams to think
that they're going to just--
OK, I'm going to do my app.
And I'll figure out
performance later on.
But that's brutal.
Super brutal.
You're leaving a lot of hard
work to the end of development.
What you want to do in
VR because performance
is critical, make it part
of your team culture.
Make it something you do
every day, twice a day.
Have a performance
cop every week
that rotates and is looking
at how things are running.
Because if you don't stay
on top of your performance
and your thermal
output, you're going
to be in trouble
later on in the game.
Last thing I want
to talk about is
audio, which I think is kind of
an unappreciated element of VR
in general and especially
on smartphones.
There's this a quote I
love from Martin O'Donnell,
the composer of the
original "Halo" series.
He said, "Music makes you
feel; sound makes it real".
And there's no
more true statement
I've heard about audio
design than that.
You can create a tremendous
amount of emotion
and a tremendous amount of
presence just through audio.
And if you think about
watts per immersion,
the amount you get
from processing
audio versus processing
visuals, it's
dramatically more efficient
what you can do with audio.
So as an example, think
about rendering a tree
or the-- you want to say,
well, there's a tree,
and the wind is blowing through
it and rustling the leaves.
Well, you can render all
the leaves on the tree
and animate them as a
way of saying, look.
The wind is blowing
through the tree.
Or you can have a sound
effect of wind rustling
and a much simpler
version of the tree,
and users are going to find
them both very plausible.
In fact, they'll
appreciate the sound more
than just the pure visuals.
And obviously, it's
dramatically cheaper
to render a simplified tree--
perhaps not that simple--
but a simplified tree with
audio than it is to render
one very complicated object.
And you can suggest
objects that aren't
there, things in the distance
that-- oh, I heard a wolf.
They must be out there-- without
rendering any wolves at all.
And since our goal really
is to create presence,
audio lets us do that really
creatively, really efficiently.
And again, as mobile
developers, we tend to be like,
oh, audio is the
last thing we do.
Make it the first thing
you do or the second
after you integrate the API.
Two other things to think
about with audio-- one
is spatial audio.
Some people like
binaural rendering.
We have technologies, and we
provide these with the Daydream
SDK that let you use
headphones but get
a sense of surround sound--
better than surround sound.
We can give you a sense
of sound above you
and below you, all around you.
It's really, really compelling.
And it makes you
feel much more--
it's much more believable than
simple stereo panning, which
is what you get by default.
You also want to think about
the way the environment affects
the audio.
If you imagine a conversation
between two people,
well, obviously
that conversation
would sound very
different in a forest
than it would sound
in a spaceship.
And our SDK has tools
that let you actually
specify the room that
you're in, the size,
the physical materials.
And it will process the
audio in a way that's
believable for that space.
So we've covered a lot today.
Really to wrap
up, all of this is
how you create a
sense of presence,
how you get below that
20 milliseconds motion
to photon latency.
We hope that that
will help you create
luscious, beautiful,
immersive, compelling VR
experiences for Daydream.
Thank you so much
for making the time.
We have tons of resources
available online.
There's the Google
Developer site,
which has a subsection on how
you can build your own Daydream
developer kit.
We have the NDK decay where
all the code that we've
talked about today comes from.
And lastly, a giant
section on spatial audio.
I've linked here to
our dev site page,
but we also had a
full session dedicated
to spatial audio
creation, technology.
It was earlier today,
but check it out online.
It'll be posted to the
main I/O channel later on.
So thank you all very much.
Thanks for being a
part of Daydream.
And maybe you can make apps
about flipping pancakes
on the beach.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]